Swiss band the Bianca story used this
video as their online platform to
publicize a drive for donations I'm Tony
muskegon baby missing earlier adiga
explained to fans that the band needed
ninety thousand euros if the project
were to succeed via the Bianca story
joint 6040 yes that this one's a music
file
ninety thousand euros that's a lot of
money for a little-known band
the Bianca story our five musicians
melding pop music with rock sounds and
melancholy lyrics as they explore a new
way of financing music recordings
the crowdfunding asks your pistol cumple
hutton we had our crowdfunding campaign
my buddy in May 2013 because we wanted
to release a new album crowd but
standard crowdfunding wasn't the right
solution anymore because we wanted to
liberate our music from the market
economy audience which is pretty
obsolete today thus father didn't mark
pitch off so that it can move freely
freely like a bird out there the
thousandth of a concussion they call
their project crowdfunding 2.0 they call
the principal everything for everyone
fans had the opportunity to donate on
crowdfunding website we make it dot CH
to finance the new album in return
supporters are kept involved and
informed the band members even posted
videos spelling out how the ninety
thousand euros would be used the wolf
author Philip and Vivian on assam tea
party you and father Fugee signaling
crisis betta fish yourself Munna to my
eczema both the same commitment to the
mission getting this oil Smith singer on
a viable explained that if they
succeeded the music would be free
but the Bianca story are hardly the
first band to use this innovative
financing model it's helped many
aspiring artists get their music to the
listeners like Dutch singer Hindle arusi
she fell out with a record label and
struck out on her own our concept every
donor gets a cut of her cds sales
revenue video game developers have also
discovered the opportunities of
crowdfunding startup companies try to
find investors through crowdfunding
sites like seed match de even the Bianca
stories record label head likes this
kind of financing that's although he
doesn't make a cent off the band's album
after its release Wiggins mosi chemistry
he ain't a taking on this whole music
industry really is or in the past hi it
mourns the good old days of flowing milk
and honey when CDs sold like hotcakes it
ignores many realities of the industry
today and I think a cool new reality is
the band's enhanced autonomy through
digital technology Devon and
crowdfunding is part of that reality
when dots a goooood Nativity else was he
cropped honey
the vianka story isn't just gifting its
CD to everyone depending on how much
they contribute donors also get
something back like a private drum
lesson from the percussionist when time
was up the band had amassed 90 1662
euros more than they needed as its Devon
seems of amazing in its online we've met
people who have helped us with the idea
you got to know about us through the
campaign and well there are audience too
so it's just great this is count yours
their album digger has been released and
it's 12 songs are available for
downloading free of charge
Oh
I am song